robert de niro grace the knitting circle
in hell known as ab you tried to link
random thoughts into a sentence joy was
there to wind him up
since he's played some of the most
unredeemable characters you have played
some of the most really unredeemable
characters was a psychopathic taxi
driver Jake LaMotta who's to beat his
wife and he was in the Raging Bull is
Trump worse than they are to me is he
has no understanding that I can see of
the outside world other than anything
around him he has no idea of what his
purpose in life is as the president
should be and that is to pull the
country together to be for the people to
heal wounds not to open them up and pour
salt on them De Niro clearly has thought
about this more so than his career his
choice of roles is now down to cinnamon
and lobster he was then asked about the
Trump kids hmm at least he doesn't want
my kids to take this the wrong way I
don't want my kids to take this the
wrong way but if my kids did what these
kids did I wouldn't want to be related
to them I would disown though whoa this
is sad here you have someone pretending
to be a tough guy turn out to be just a
second banana for joy behar the poster
child for trumped arrangement sadly bob
is now just another gibbering enfeebled
ninny surrounded by inept relatives as
he frets about how trump's in power and
he's not see Trump's rise coincides with
De Niro's decline and the person who
knows it most is De Niro he's a fine
example of how not to turn loss into
bitterness there are plenty of people
who don't like Trump but don't let it
warp their minds with their ability to
speak aloud among grown-ups or the view
but the shifts in De Niro's of the world
are emotionally damaged by politics to a
point where they can't even assess their
own emotions being an actor is tough for
how does one handle real life without a
script not equipped to think
analytically you're left powerless when
observing your own predictions about
life turn out wrong it's not supposed to
be this way De Niro thinks only the cool
guys get to win sorry Bob that's only in
the movies but at least you'll always
have
joy you know um when dislike is so
emotional Katie I always think it means
something else like he's actually
thought about this like you know he said
it's in his head and I wonder I can't
help but think it's because they're a
similar age and they're both New Yorkers
something has Blake yeah it's like
personal it's like Jerry Nadler thing
with Trump is also very personal robert
Moeller had a personal spat with Trump I
mean to let it eat you alive like that
and led to control your entire being I
think is actually pretty sad and
pathetic and it's also a lazy argument
so when he attacks the Trump kids as
saying he would disown them it doesn't
really give examples as to why you know
Ivanka Trump for example went into the
administration got rid of her own
business after being a successful
businesswoman it started this global
women's development project that allows
for women to get into the workforce
she's been able to change the law in a
number of countries now that allow women
to own property making a real impact on
people's lives but yet he's here saying
that if they were his children he would
disown them I mean they're doing real
work for real people not just in America
but all around the world and that's the
only argument they can come up with hmm
Jesse it's amazing we went from Raging
Bull to Joy's assistant all right DeNiro
is a bad interviewer I mean he's a good
actor but have you ever seen him on a
set with a TV host it's like pulling
teeth he's so boring and he's always
been bad and a lazy guest but now the
media has found something that makes him
interesting yeah and they're exploiting
his Trump derangement syndrome for
ratings and to score political points
but it's sad though because you can see
that's all he has he seems a little
obsessed and he's a great actor but he's
kind of destroying his brand a little
bit here I'm not saying conservatives
aren't gonna watch his movie they
obviously have but this is one of the
reasons why conservatives don't watch
these shows you don't want to see this
old angry guy to try to just take the
president's head off and have joy help
him out doing that and then sell TV ads
off that it's just cheap and people tune
out now to say that Donald Trump is out
of touch with the country
that's crazy I mean he's he's sometimes
too in touch with what's good what we
won he's the man of the people he's got
the finger on the pulse and I don't
think he's divided the country I think
the media is divided you're turning into
Fred Sanford looking for one
the Irishman is pretty good I didn't
like it let me just say he was terrific
like it or not he was Joe Pesci great
Jonathan actually was Jonathan Morris
amazing but he was terrible because of
CGI I screwed up his face okay but I
happen to body of work is excellent
actor but I will says I'm listening to
you guys about this angry old man I'm
thinking hmm this week I heard this
angry old man go after this 16 year old
girl then he was talking about Nero you
know you're right to talk about Trump
but not it's okay not okay to talk about
Trump but it's okay to talk about DeNiro
it seems to me like nobody goes
Hollywood you know and says oh let's
just leave this alone it's just an actor
only conservatives pay attention to
these actors role model right I think
that's right it's just an actor exactly
the way don't don't get too worked up
about it everybody but I do think
there's a little progress on the
civility front how so this is the first
clip we have shown of Robert DeNiro
talking about Trump where he hasn't used
the f-word
that is you know what I apologize to
Robert DeNiro I totally missed that
progress being made and I also think
that joy and Robert make a great couple
and I could see them hosting a show
together not as tight I don't know a
little fire